hallo das video vergleich sehen werdet
ist überhaupt nicht gut geschnitten und
ich habe auch nicht die musik irgendwie
auch uns ausgeblendet oder run gesund
oder soweit das video grad im auto aber
alle dateien vergessen hallo wer du bist
du herzlich willkommen wir heute zahlen
ein video hinter hauptsaison bis freitag
das heißt heute kommt wieder mal
minecraft und ich habe etwas ganz
besonderes geschafft ihr seht es hier
schon eingeblendet ich befinde mich auf
einem server und kann hier rumlaufen ja
die letzten male immer irgendwelchen
videos das problem dass ich mich nicht
registrieren konnte das ganze irgendwie
nicht geklappt
ok ich ertrinke gerade bisher war es
immer so ich bin auf den server gibt
wollt mich registriert / vista / locken
das hat alles nie geklappt und jetzt
eine ganz kurze sache hier an alle leute
die mir unter das letzte video
geschrieben haben zu lappen newsletter
machen
ihr habt alle keine ahnung sorry dass
ich das jetzt sage aber ich hatte ja
menschen die ein auf große klappe im
internet mache rum beleidigen meinen sie
seien die aller coolsten und wissen
alles und dann einfach nur scheiße
verzapfen die gar nicht stimmt wie
konnten sich noch eine person
weiterhelfen das war tobi nature hd ist
glaube ich ein fan von terminator
da hätten wir nämlich geschrieben dass
ich alle namen besitzen er auf dem
server eventuell schon vorhanden ist
deswegen hab ich meinen namen geändert
und konnte dann die ganzen prozesse
durchlaufen und dann hat's geklappt und
er hat mir das ganze freundlich und nett
geschrieben und die anderen sind jetzt
alle blockiert deswegen sind jetzt hier
gerade in game und ich weiß jetzt
allerdings auch nicht ganz genau wo ich
jetzt hier gerade hingelangt lobby geht
nicht wenn ich mal lobby mache dann
immer wieder neu
diese server ist es möglich dass ich
irgendwie hunger games
als auch spielen kann da minigames genau
darauf ich bevor wir das allerdings
jetzt gleich mal machen wo sie neue
kleine sache schnell sagen die
aufmerksame zuschauer von euch wissen
nämlich heute ist freitag der siebzehnte
sechster manager video gerade wenn sonne
jedes ist vielleicht gerade kurz nach
fünf oder so das heißt dass gerade
dieses kissel und zwei neue t-shirts der
minister vde klatscht sind und es gibt
zu diesem kissen und den t shirt wenn
ihr das bestellen gibt's 1000 signierte
flyer und noch 50 special edition flyer
die von beiden seiten signiert sind also
habt ihr quasi den doppelter
unterschrift deswegen freunde weil ich
so viele kommentare immer bekomme dann
zu jule lukan conzelmann denn wie ihr es
jetzt draußen ist es der oberst winkler
beschreibung seien schnell ich will
garnicht bewerbung machen aber bevor du
heute ankommen ich hab keinen platz
bekommen dass verletzt weil demnach
stunde so deswegen sagen jetzt hier habt
ihr die möglichkeit ich halte jetzt
nicht meine schnauze aber seinen schnell
und beschwert euch nicht wenn ihr keine
flyer mehr bekommen weil da
wahrscheinlich schon wechseln ich frage
mich allerdings auch gerade die solch
eine komische teile an meinem körper ihr
dran habe die mich irgendwie an etwas
festhalten aber gut wir wollen ja
irgendwas socke deswegen schauen wir
jetzt mal was wir dann alles um waren
können wir haben hier ihr account
register das ist ja super cool
da wir hier stehen hier ist man
irgendwie den der advents und so wir
sind trading rooms trading ruf noch mehr
trading rooms dort überhaupt keine
werbung für den server seien allerdings
war selbst der einzige ruhig so richtig
darauf freuen konnte hier fordere was
weg schildern jetzt da intel developer
ich glaube dass da vorne sind die mini
games oder es ist halt wirklich so
fucking schwierig herumzulaufen in
diesem spiel alter ich rutsche die ganze
zeit von den sanierer so more coming
was haben dass sich das sieht nach mini
games auf die steuerung umgestellt
ich bin immer diese komischen teile in
meinem körper kleben
hallo doch da ob ihr es glaubt oder
nicht aber ich wollte gerade auf von
mini-games joint auf einmal stützt
minecraft ab was ist dieses pocket
edition für eine scheiße und dann habe
ich wieder alles neu gestartet aufnahme
oder wollte ich komm ich beim pvp rating
von telepo ding ist eingehend an slim
anderen menschen stets minecraft wieder
ab also an alle pocket edition soccer
unter euch warum spielt diesen scheißer
stützt dauern guckt euch einmal das ja
nicht laufen nach vorne und bin jetzt
hier in die im hortbereich und wenn ich
jetzt nicht da warum warum es ist es ist
einfach fakt abgestürzt es ist einfach
abgespült ich zeig euch das jetzt mal
hier werde ich befinde mich auf dem
server laufen nur in diesem bereich
recht schönen abend ich habe nichts
getan an lange liebe hält alle draußen
bis hin zu einem kommentar lese auch
lokale presse wird tiefer wahrscheinlich
liegt an meinem handy os und brandneues
16 es die pid das ist die neueste
minecraft pocket edition mo yan hater
wenn ihr das seht ihr mich verarschen
sein scheiß wurde vom licht war ich
richtig krise diesen charakter also dann
kaufe ich mir mein von pocket edition
für fünf euro
40 millionen euro im appstore nikab
nicht klar ob er geld dafür dass es
immer absturz auf jedem server 150
tausender leitungen internet iphone 6 es
das neueste was apple auf dem markt hat
die neueste version minecraft pocket
edition und ich mache alles richtig
laufen stets ab
sorry ich hätte ultra gerne online
minecraft pocket edition gespielt weil
das noch nie gemacht habe ihn schaut mal
mein handy heißt luca ich habe das noch
nie gemacht und ist der ultra cool
gewesen sondern bis ihr dann freitag
jetzt mal nicht nur ganz normal
minecraft zu zocken sondern online auf
dem handy zusammen aber es geht nicht ob
ich heule fast gerade ich hab die tränen
schon in den augen da keine ahnung dass
man sozusagen das video weil es einfach
wie ich über den server gelaufen bin und
ein bisschen gesagt habe dass das
kitzeln jetzt in dem shop ist und ist es
wahrscheinlich schon raus verkauft also
braucht eigentlich gar nicht mehr im
shop vorbei schauen und dann will ich
einfach auf einem server zäunen und da
zucken wir dann jetzt einfach nicht weil
es einfach minecraft kann es nicht
gewährleisten dass ich irgendwie einen
allein in unserem raum reingehen
es funktioniert einfach nicht das ist
das kann doch alles nicht wahr sein
deswegen will ich dass wir jetzt an
dieser stelle beenden freunde wie
behälter liebe besserwisser schreibt mir
die kommentare was ich diesmal falsch
gemacht habe wahrscheinlich muss
darlegen wie es liegt nur mit die area
zu kommen und sonst sehen wir sind im
nächsten video wieder ich will gar nicht
daran lassen dort hinterlassen bewährt
und das wollte ich meine es ist mir
scheißegal
sorry ich bin ein bisschen aggressiv
gerade ich wollte nochmal
zusammengefasst bei allem respekt ich
lag mir diese app und herren ich hoffe
diese ich informiere mich darüber wie
ich auf einem server spielen kann auf
drei verschiedenen servern geht's nicht
das kann nicht mehr an mir wir sehen uns
morgen in dem nächsten video wieder
video bauen wir übrigens sehr cool also
wirklich